من جنوب عسقلان مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
وسيكون معنا ايضا من غزه مراسلنا هناك لكن
نبدا بك الياس ما الجديد في التحصينات
الاسرائيليه والاستعدادات الاسرائيليه في
غلاف غزه
نعم زين يبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول
جر المقاومه الفلسطينيه الى رد فعل بعد
هذه الساعات الطويله من الهجوم من الهدوء
والجيش الاسرائيلي يؤكد في الدقائق
الاخيره بانه استهدف خليه تابعه للجهاد
الاسلامي جنوب قطاع غزه تحديدا في منطقه
خان يونس ويقول بانه بان هذه الخليه كانت
تستعد لاطلاق قذائف صاروخيه باتجاه
اسرائيل او ربما صواريخ مضاده للدروع كما
حدث بالامس عندما اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي
استهداف خليه تابعه للجهاد الاسلامي في
تلك المنطقه تحديدا لكن واضح بان الصمت
وعدم الرد من الجانب الفلسطيني يقلق ويربك
حسابات
الجانب الاسرائيلي تحديدا المستوى العسكري
والمستوى السياسي ويبدو ان استهداف هذه
الخلايا
بالتحديد اذا كانت بالفعل تستعد لاطلاق
صواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل او قذائف مضاده
للدروع لكن من الواضح ان اسرائيل تحاول ان
تتبع تكتيكا جديدا بعد هذه الساعات
الطويله من الصمت ومحاوله ربما جر
المقاومه الى رد فعل غير محسوب من طرفها
في اطار هذه المواجهه على هذا الصعيد نشير
ايضا بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل جهوده في
الساعات الاخيره وكما فعل طيله الليله
الماضيه في تحصين المناطق الحدوديه
وتحديدا البلدات القريبه من خط المواجهه
القريبه من السياج الامني كبلده ناحيه
العوز
واكفار عزه هذه بعض من البلدات الواقعه في
غلاف غزه والاقرب ربما الى السياج الامني
وبالتالي هي عرضه لصواريخ كورنيت او
الصواريخ الموجهه ضد الدروع وبالتالي قوات
الجيش الاسرائيلي تحاول ان تقيم في هذه
البلدات وتحديدا على المحاور المؤديه
اليها تحصينات من كتل اسمنتيه لحجب الرؤيه
عنها عن المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي
بامكانها ان تسدد بالنسافات قصيره عبر
السياج الامني هذه الصواريخ المضاده
للضروع في اهداف داخل هذه البلدات
الاسرائيليه عدا عن ذلك قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي تواصل اغلاق طرق رئيسيه عده في
هذه المناطق الحدوديه كهذا الطريق الرئيس
الوصل بين شمال قطاع غزه ومناطق وسط
اسرائيل تقيم العديد من الحواجز العسكريه
والشرطيه
وتمنع تحرك الاسرائيليين على هذه المحاور
المكشوفه كي لا يكون ايضا عرضه لاستهدافات
من جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه بصواريخ
الكورنيت الموجهه نحن نتحدث عن مناطق
شاسعه ومفتوحه على امتداد نحو 65 كيلو
مترا حول قطاع غزه هذه هنالك كثير من
الشوارع الرئيسه المكشوفه على القطاع
بمعنى نحن نتحدث عن مناطق سهله لا يوجد
جبال لا يوجد تلال تحجب الرؤيه عن
المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي من السهل تسديد ضربات
صاروخيه لكل من يسلك هذه المحاور سواء
كانوا اسرائيليين او سواء كان ذلك اليات
عسكريه تتحرك في هذه المناطق لذلك هنالك
اغلاق تام لهذه الشوارع في محيط غلاف مع
ذلك ومن اعتام لاي من الاسرائيليين التحرك
على هذه المحور ومع ذلك تنقل وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه عن مسؤول اسرائيلي
قوله انه لا يمكن مواصله حاله الطوارئ
بالبلدات الجنوبيه اذا لم يتم اطلاق قذائف
من غزه يعني هذه الحاله حاله الاستنفار
يبدو ان هنالك حاله نفات منها
بالتاكيد هذا ما قلته في المداخله الاخيره
بان اسرائيل لا يمكنها ان تبقى في حاله
انتظار لمده طويله والصمت والسيد الموقف
وهذا هو التكتيك الذي لم تعاهده من قبل من
جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه بالعاده
المقاومه الفلسطينيه كانت ترد ردا سريعا
على اي عدوان تشنه اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
لاسيما واستهداف قادتها الميدانيين
والعسكريين او حتى في المستوى السياسي لكن
هذا التكتيك الجديد الذي تتبعه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالفعل يربك كل الحسابات
المنظومه السياسيه والامنيه
والاستخباراتيه اسرائيل لا تعرف ما الذي
تتوقعه لا في الساعات القادمه ولا في
الايام القادمه وبالتالي بامكان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ان تجر اسرائيل في هذه الحاله
لايام لاسابيع وربما لشهر واكثر وبالتالي
اسرائيل لا يمكنها ان تبقى في هذه الحاله
من الارباك في هذه الحاله
من الضبابيه انت ترى هذا الاغلاق للشوارع
الرئيسيه وهذا لا يقتصر فقط على الشوارع
وحركه الاسرائيليين هنا هذا ايضا يسبب
خسائر اقتصاديه فادحه سوف تتضح معالمها
بعد انتهاء هذه المواجهه
40 كيلومترا او 50 كم الحركه فيها معطله
هنالك اسئله كثيره في الداخل ايضا يعني
مثلا تصريح وزيره المخابرات ان هناك من
يحاول جر اسرائيل الى حمل اكبر في قطاع
غزه هل هنالك تفسيرات لهذا لهذا التصريح
من المقصود
هو المقصود بالتالي المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وليس فقط المقاومه الفلسطينيه في داخل
قطاع غزه هنالك بطبيعه الحال اتهامات
مبطنه من جانب اسرائيل تحاول ان توجه سهام
الانتقادات او الاتهامات ايضا للمقاومه
اللبنانيه لحزب الله تحديدا وايضا لايران
الذي اشار رئيس الوزراء من يمين بانه
الممول الرئيس لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
بمعنى ان اسرائيل تحاول ان تدخل بعض
الجهات الاقليميه في الاقليم في المحيط
وكان هذه الجهات هي مسؤوله ايضا عن حاله
الارباك السائده حاليا في داخل اسرائيل
وتحديدا هنا على تقوم قطاع غزه بمعنى ان
اسرائيل لا تنتظر فقط الرد من جانب
المقاومه الفلسطينيه هنا في القطاع وهذا
ما كان المح به ايضا اليه المسؤولون
السياسيون والعسكريون في اسرائيل عندما
قالوا بان اسرائيل تستعد لايام من
المواجهه وتستعد لي ايضا احتمال ان تقوم
بالرد او ان تعمل عسكريا وتنشط عسكريا على
جبهات متعدده المقصود في ذلك بان اسرائيل
تنتظر الرد من كل مكان الان ليس فقط من
داخل قطاع غزه وقد لا ياتي بالفعل الرد من
داخل قطاع غزه قد ياتي الرد من جنوب لبنان
او من مناطق اخرى او حتى من داخل الضفه
الغربيه المحتله لذلك اسرائيل لا عليها ان
تتوقع كل شيء في الساعات المقبله وليس
بالضروره ان ياتي الرد هنا لذلك هي تحمل
المسؤوليه الى جهات اقليميه بطبيعه الحال
انت تعلم بان اسرائيل توجه اصابع الاتهام
لايران وتقول بان النظام الايراني هو
الممول الاكبر لكل التنظيمات الارهابيه
كما تسميها اسرائيل في المنطقه والتي تعمل
ضد اسرائيل وبالتالي يعني اسرائيل الان في
حاله استعداد واستنفار على اكثر من جبهه
نحن نعلم بان الجيش الاسرائيلي وضع من
القبه الحديديه والمنظمات الدفاعيه الاخرى
على اغبه الاستعداد القصوى ليس فقط هنا في
غلاف غزه انما في وسط اسرائيل في منطقه تل
ابيب الكبرى وكذلك هو الحال على المنطقه
الشماليه الحدوديه مع لبنان وتذكر بانها
كان هنالك هجوم صاروخي في مطلع نيسان
ابريل الماضي حيث اطلقت اكثر من 35 قذيفه
صاروخيه باتجاه البلدات الاسرائيليه
المتاخمه للحدود مع لبنان وكانت اسرائيل
قد وجهت اصابع الاتهام مباشره الى حركه
حماس في جنوب لبنان بان هي المسؤوله عن
هذا التنظيم وهنالك فقط بجمله وفي عجاله
نشير الى ان اسرائيل ترى بان هنالك ترابط
وتعاضد ووحده حال بين كل فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه والمقاومه في الاقليم من من
حولها
الياس كرام من جنوب عسقلان مراسله الجزيره
شكرا جزيلا